and thanks for staying with us at 6 30.
i'm denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
new numbers from las vegas realtors show
another new record for average housing
prices about 482 000 that's for a
single-family home and then last month
also setting a new record for condo and
townhome prices they at about 285
thousand but there are changes to the
market as more homes are for sale joe
mueller is near decatur in desert in
with what experts are noticing
home prices continue to rise here in
southern nevada as interest rates go up
more homes are now on the market it is a
trend we have been seeing since just
about the start of the pandemic home
prices rising at a fast rate and selling
faster than ever that was until last
month las vegas realtors say there are
not as many homes selling and that more
are hitting the market but prices are
still rising more than 2 700 homes were
put up for sale last month that did not
get an offer that's up more than 75
percent from a year ago brian kruger is
the senior vice president for strategic
services at coldwell banker supply is
still is still very low even though it
has gone up we attribute some of that
more to just demand
going down a little bit and i think we
can attribute that
in large part to um you know almost a
you know a little over two percent
increase in interest rates from where we
were say 120 days ago he says it is
still a good time to sell as inventory
is still considered low he says las
vegas is still doing well when looking
at other markets we're faring better
than the california markets than than
phoenix and phoenix
i think in large part because we're
still the most quote unquote affordable
the president of the las vegas realtor
says local existing home prices have
quadrupled since hitting their lowest
point after the recession in january of
2012. reporting in las vegas joe mohler
live local now